للفيديو يا دكتور خليل العناني استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا
بك دكتور خليل يعني تصريحات صحفيه استمعنا
اليها لكن الى اي مدى تظهر
التوافق او الاختلاف العميق والجوهري في
المواقف بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
برايك نعتقد هناك فرق كبير بين الموقفين
واضح جدا هناك اصرار على المدير قدماء
فيما يتعلق
بالاستفاده من وجود حكوميه في هشام متطرفه
وبالتالي القيام بما لم تقوم بها من قبل
من جهه اخرى هناك محاوله امريكيه للتهدئه
في اطار عدم اندلاع حرب جديده العالم
جميعا انه في عهد نتنياهو على الاقل اربع
حروف من الستات التي حدثت خلال اخر 10
سنين تمت في عهدنا بها وهتستخدم هذه
الحيله باستمرار تغلق قفزه الامام سواء
لقضايا داخليه متعلقه بالانتخابات او
متعلقه بالفساد او المحكمه العليا كم يحدث
وبالتالي نحن الاذاء مرحله قد تكون معتده
لكنها مختلفه في ظل وجود حكومه متطرفه قد
تضع امريكا في احراج على عكس مكانه من قبل
وبالتالي هناك حرص امريكي طب دلع الامور
لا احد يعرف قد كذا الامور بيتجه حرب
جديده وبالتالي نوع من وجود نوع من
الاحراج الامريكي اللي بيتعلق بهذه
المساله
يعني ما دلاله هذه هذا الاختلاف في
المواقف كيف يمكن ان يترجم في هذه المرحله
اتحدث عنها لا اعتقد بك اختلاف كبير
استاذه ايمان هناك محاوله فقط لعدم خروج
الامور عن السيطره بمعنى اخر هناك دعم
امريكا غير محدود اداره بين الاداره ضعيفه
مهتزه مرتعشه ومشغوله بقضايا اخرى على
اساسا
الحربرانيه العلاقه مع الصين الملف النانو
والقراءه ليس هناك يعني ضغط امريكي حقيقي
امريكي ليست هناك امكانيه للقيام مثلا فرض
عقبات على اسرائيل هذا الامر على الاطلاق
رغم ان هناك انتهاكات كثيره جدا على سبيل
المثال مثلا حتى دي لحظه لما يتم التحقيق
الجاد في مقتل الزميله عقل رغم انها موطنه
امريكيه فلسطينيه وبالتالي من الصعب جدا
يتم اخذ اي تصريحات امريكيه امام احمد
الجلديه كما قلت فقط محاوله لحفظ ماء
الوجه ده الرامات في العيون من خلال
دفع الحكومه الفاشيه للجميع الان الا تذهب
بعيدا عن امريكا في موقف محرج في متعلق
باحتمال قيام حرب مع الفلسطينيين في
الفتره المقبله